en têt dans le nord de la france à une
vingtaine de kilomètres de l'île des
villageois sont réunis dans une salle
qu'on appelle ici un gallodrome un lieu
où sont organisés des combats de coqs
un spectacle étonnant
freddy ne fait qu'un avec son animal
continue garçons la règle est simple
deux coques armée de piquant métal sur
les pattes six minutes de combat celui
qui reste debout et le vainqueur et son
coq vient d'être tué par son adversaire
les combats de coqs sont interdits en
france les contrevenants risquent
jusqu'à 30000 euros d'amendé et deux ans
de prison
sauf dans le nord pas de calais et dans
les dom tom où ils sont autorisés car
c'est là que la tradition a toujours été
la plus forte une tradition centenaire
une façon de se divertir à peu de frais
à l'origine les paysans organisé des
combats de coqs pour régler leurs
différends et éviter de se battre mais
comme la tauromachie c'est une tradition
qui fait hurler les défenseurs de la
nature
non
il y a aujourd'hui deux mille éleveurs
de coqs de combat dans la région des coq
leur comme on les appelle ils ont leur
propre championnat
et chaque semaine ils parient sur leur
meilleur coque les coques gladiateurs
s'agit-il d'une pratique barbare ou d'un
divertissement populaire à protéger
freddy et son père sont de véritables
mordus de coke
ils vivent à chocques à côté de béthune
dans une maison familiale qu'ils ont
transformée en ferrain ici plus de 150
coque tous élevés pour en faire des
combattants un soldat en premier et ça
commence par un régime spécial champions
alors là alors on leur donne la ration
pour hautbois deux jours on a un doublé
de l'eau et après sur le court ce qu'on
va préparer pour aller au combat lors de
la petite graine
ils sont là c'est beaucoup le sénégal
qui leur donne du du punk a provoqué
soit bien qu'on appelait puisqu'on
revient en bonne condition pour mettre
toutes les chances du de notre côté pour
la victoire il ya 18 mois
5-4 combat celui qui a fait deux combats
celui là et jamais joué mais si quinze
jours trois semaines il va pouvoir aller
faire ses preuves au combat
alors ça vous vient de cette passion à
moi ça me vient de mon père
un tuyau il m'a donné un coq et là bas
je fais les gens les plus vieux ajouté
parti élu lui dit tu peux tu mets le nez
avec
alors donc lui il est né dedans ben
saada bonheur valeur freddy à 38 ans il
est bouché et les coqs de combat sont
une passion qui lui coûtent des milliers
d'euros par an ils passent aussi trois
heures par jour à s'occuper de ces bêtes
des poussins jusqu'aux cote prêts au
combat
le père le fils et le petit-fils rémy 8
ans déjà initié à l'amour des
combattants en plus mais je serai fier
qui est continu qui prend un autre
chemin que quelques mba obame dit plus
rien ça sera pareil pour moi je ne
voudrais pas mais je donnerai les bases
petit à petit il initie son fils à
l'élevage de ces gladiateurs
ja
voilà quatre ans que tu portes de
castres
freddy dorlote presque plus et coke que
son épouse que les cheveux parce que je
passe beaucoup de temps peut se mettre
en règle avec la famille élève une race
appelé combattants du nord connus pour
leur agressivité naturelle plus fort en
dire plus gros rap et leur caractère
combattants maintenant place aux choses
sérieuses freddy doit jauger ses coques
déterminer lequel pourrait être son
futur champion il masque les griffes de
ces animaux pas question qu'il se blesse
avant le combat
là on va faire un essayage voir comment
il se comporte dans le combat c'est
reparti nev comment ils tapent si rapide
s'il est précis et pour ses coques pas
besoin d'encouragements à peine posé sur
le sol
ils s'affrontent
alors bien essayé tous les deux celui-ci
sa levée un petit peu plus haut un peu
plus haut et jouer plus plus subtil mais
il est plus léger aussi donc quand ils
sont plus âgés sont plus subtiles freddy
doit sélectionner un de ces gladiateurs
pour la semaine suivante il fera son
choix au dernier moment
ces jours de combats aujourd'hui à tours
min les défenseurs des animaux sont sur
le pont est-ce que je suis jolie
[Musique]
après les fausses notes le fond
d'affrontements sur une musique de
circonstance les antilles combats sont
prêts à tout pour la cause
mais les habitants ne sont pas au rendez
vous personne n'est là pour les écouter
à part nous aujourd'hui on est là pour
les coqs et le coq aujourd'hui c'est le
symbole de la vie c'est le symbole de
tous ces êtres qui sont martyrisés
torture et partout dans le monde
en france aussi uniquement parce qu'ils
ne sont que des objets il décide alors
de se diriger vers le gallodrome le lieu
du combat
accompagné par la marche funèbre de
chopin de son côté le père de freddy
affûte les armes qu'il accrochera aux
pattes des animaux pour le combat de
tout à l'heure j'entendais polir pour
qu'elle soit bien propre et bien les
huit films comme ça mais picot mais pas
trop enchanteur pas tranchante pour ne
pas mutiler les coques mémoire batterie
le coq et dans cette caisse depuis la
veille pour qu'il soit bien au chaud et
au calme les trois générations sont
prêts à partir au combat au gallodrome
les coquelets raciste amusé à l'arrivée
de la manif pas de confrontation la
gendarmerie veille
de toute façon ça fait bien rigoler le
propriétaire de l'établissement
c'est folklorique en ont un peu
publicité pour le gallodrome quoi
ça nous donnera pas un dans le
gallodrome il est temps pour freddy
d'armes et son animal il joue dans 20
minutes pour l'artère faire
[Musique]
on pense à sur la voiture une douille
ensuite on met les larmes et en foot on
met le cuir les ficelles pressés qui
essayait de le faire assez rapidement
pour paul le troll chahutée puis
l'énervé co freddy a bien choisi son coq
il a l'oeil pour sa bien rougissent il
est gonflé ici en dessous il ya onze ans
ça veut dire finir il a gagné deux fois
en championnat
[Musique]
l'avenir nous le dira
pendant que les coques attendent
sagement dans leur boîte coq leur et
amateurs achètent leur place dans la
salle
les combats ont déjà commencé il y en
aura 25 ans tous ils sont 150 à être
venus assister au spectacle tous d'un
certain âge tous des passionnés comme
gisèle une ancienne coqueluche depuis
toujours et c'est là la preuve on peut
pas faire autrement et au début c'était
me coq et théo pas que j'étais obligé de
sortir je pouvais partager encore se
battre
j'étais dans un état d'épuisement tenant
au fil du temps le rituel est toujours
le même on met les bêtes en condition
avant le combat dans les tribunes
gisèle ne s'est pas vraiment assagie
elle vibre avec l'animal
[Musique]
mais m'écoute pas ma vie je suis méchant
font mal j'ai maîtrisé avant chaque
combat les paris vont bon train
les amateurs cris la cote de leurs
favoris les jeux d'argent sont très
réglementés en france
mais ici pas de problème tradition
oblige les paris sont autorisés de la
main à la main un autre spectateur mais
les sommes récoltées reste raisonnable
le dénommé hubert vient de gagner
quelques dizaines d'euros avant de faire
match nul sur le combat suivant il
récupère juste sa mise ici jamais 250
euros paris mais on fait nul
en moyenne les parieurs misent une
vingtaine d'euros par combat en une
journée ils peuvent remporter plusieurs
centaines d'euros
mais c'est rare ici on joue avant tout
pour l'amour des coqs
je commence à connaître les copies tous
les fonds monétaires ont confectionné
des bombes et quelques failles de
carcans suis intouchable
c'est maintenant au tour de freddy et de
son coq petit bleu pour l'élever on l'a
soignée
ça lui a
on a fait le nécessaire maintenant la
balle est dans son camp son père près
par l'animal avec son petit fils tension
jette au rétro bien
double c'est le gris cendré lecoq de
free dit qu'ils dominent en moins de
deux minutes petit bleu blesse son
adversaire
j'ai gagné a pas de casser en tant que
vainqueur sans parier
freddy a gagné 75 euros petit bleu on
est à quatre victoires pour autant de
combats depuis qu'il a commencé sa
carrière
freddy et son fils rémy sont contents de
leur champion on est bien rentré fort
tous les deux et ça va bien levé mais
l'avantagé qu'il ya bien mis ses pas de
nos ventes et quand tu as bien allongé
la passe à prédire et en plus il est pas
obligé freddy's semble avoir assuré la
relève
mais la tradition se perd il y a de
moins en moins de combats de coqs dans
le nord pas de calais
[Musique]
un type à l'heure